الأجانب
على مدى العقود القليلة الماضية في المغرب ، زادت
نسبة السكان الذين يكملون
التعليم الثانوي والجامعي
بشكل كبير وفقًا
للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
في عام 2015 ، حددت الحكومة
مهمة طموحة لمعالجة بعض التحديات في
قطاع التعليم
يركز برنامجها على ضمان  تكافؤ الفرص
بين شبابها وتشكيل
مهنيين أكثر استباقية واندفاعًا اليوم ،
تجني المملكة ثمار
هذه الجهود مع زيادة
عدد الطلاب في التعليم العالي
بأكثر من 30 بالمائة بين عامي 2017 و 2022
وفقًا للبيانات الوطنية
الآن هنا في العالم  القمة الحكومية التي
التقيت بها مع وزير
التعليم العالي المغربي لمعرفة ما هي
الخطط لتعزيز الفترة الأكاديمية في المملكة
على مستوى عالمي ، نحن نواجه
فترة مهمة للغاية نشهد فيها
تحولات كبيرة ، مستقبل
التعليم الجامعي يهدف إلى
تدريب فردي للتمكين
وعقول أكثر مرونة أعتقد أن ما
شهدناه في السنوات الأخيرة يوضح أنه من
الأفضل تعلم كيفية التعلم بدلاً من
فرض المعلومات على الشباب
وأعتقد أنه يجب إدخال الجيل الجديد
في هذا المجال من التعلم  على
المستوى الإقليمي ،
تتأكد من أنه على نفس
المستوى مع النمو الاقتصادي مع
الأفكار التي لدى الحكومات في
المنطقة لتصبح تعرف
الاقتصادات الحديثة وخاصة في
مجال التكنولوجيا حيث يجلس المغرب فيما
يتعلق بأقرانه
يجب علينا في نفس الوقت  الاستجابة
للمجال الاجتماعي والاقتصادي وتطور
المغرب ، لكن يجب علينا أيضًا الرد على
كيفية انجذاب شبابنا
نحو البلدان الأخرى ، على سبيل المثال ، إذا
تناولت حالة الطب ، فقد قمنا بتدريب
حوالي 1500 طبيب العام الماضي ثم
غادر نصفهم إلى ألمانيا  فرنسا
وأوروبا لذلك لدينا خسارة في
الشباب المؤهلين المتعلمين جيدًا ،
نحن نفقد الكثير من المهندسين أيضًا ، لذلك نحن
في هذه الحالة علينا
الاستجابة لطلبنا الداخلي على
المستوى الاجتماعي والاقتصادي ولكن في نفس الوقت
لدينا  هجرة الأدمغة
التي نعيشها بشكل واضح
كتحدي وكقيد
للسنوات المقبلة ، يمول البنك الدولي
جهودًا في المغرب للتعليم الابتدائي
والثانوي ، كيف سيجعل ذلك
حياتك أفضل وأسهل عندما
تكون  التركيز على التعليم العالي وجعل
الأطفال ينتقلون من جزء من
مسيرتك المدرسية إلى النظام التالي ، النظام التعليمي
يحتاج نظام التعليم والتدريب المغربي إلى التحول وكل هذا
يتطلب وسائل لتدريب
المدربين على وسائل التكنولوجيا لأن
التكنولوجيا اليوم تلعب دورًا في
التنمية  أعتقد أن البنك الدولي
والعديد من المنظمات الدولية الأخرى
يمكن أن تساعد على وجه التحديد في هذا
التحول ،
وكما أقول غالبًا ، فإن المغرب مثله مثل
البلدان الأخرى في القارة الأفريقية
لا يقوم فقط بتدريب الشباب لنفسه ، بل إنه
يدرب أيضًا لدول أخرى غنية
لأن الشباب
منجذبون للذهاب إلى هناك ويجب علينا
الاستجابة والعمل معًا تمامًا
لأن الجامعة عالمية
[موسيقى]